hallo mein name ist supernett willkommen
leute zu einem neuen videos little rio
kommt ja bei euch mal relativ gut an
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht ich
informiere mich mal bei anderen youtuber
und im internet ob es dafür nicht einen
weg gibt
und da bin ich auf bb von max gestoßen
max hat nämlich auch den sogenannten
ehec in dem video benutzt ich zeige euch
davon jetzt mal einen kleinen ausschnitt
und ich bin down kann man machen max
also mit einem hack zu verpacken ist auf
jeden fall sehr gut wir sind ja auch
schon halb in game sieht schon ich habe
das hier drin sind zwar steht hier
creator party konsum custombike blogger
graphic shortcut steht also wir haben
sehr setzt viele neue funktionen können
hier außer dem was wir für einen tag
haben wollte er sich nicht einfach mal
mg nenne mich luca und die sache ist
nämlich jetzt da wenig aufspielen drücke
den ich erlebt hier erst mal kurz ein
paar sekunden später ich bin unsichtbar
und fahre hier durch die welt das ist
quasi ein invisible heck irgendwie also
ungewollt aber naja wir haben
möglichkeiten des ruhmes und raussuchen
als ich kann noch ganz weit weg zoomen
überblick zu verschaffen um zu sehen wo
er sachen sind die ich essen kann oder
so also hier und bin ich jetzt gerade
jetzt esse ich dieses gelbe ding hier
schnell auf jetzt beispielsweise die
hier sind ein paar rote die kann ich
ganz gut fressen
ich bin tot besser war
ich fahre hier quasi als unsichtbare
schlange rum und kann andere sachen
essen oder halt nicht essen und die
sache ist wenn leute keinen namen haben
dann sieht man halt auch keinen namen
deswegen sehe ich die leg das heißt ich
könnte theoretisch jeden moment eine
schlange reinfahren dass nämlich die
ersten beiden funktionen vom heck ich
meine es kein richtiger heck ist eine
erweiterung aber erweiterungen komisch
aber gerät das ganze als mit plus also
wir sind hier irgendwie teils unsichtbar
und wir können raus und rein soll
allerdings weiß ich jetzt woran es liegt
dass ich unsichtbar bin ich versuche mal
eben in einer genau so jetzt bin ich tot
und jetzt seht ihr nämlich schon
milchkartons kimmel täter ein klick und
wenn ich jetzt auf kleingärten drücken
müsste ich eigentlich wieder einen jeden
haargenau da bin ich mein das kind
wechselt allerdings die ganze zeit das
ist quasi die nächste erweiterung und
zwar hab ich jetzt bin ich weiß jetzt
bin ich so grüne brasilien frage jetzt
habe ich eine dings der bla bla
ich konnte ihn wechseln das ist quasi
die erweiterung ablass und ich habe mir
gedacht das leider ja schon jetzt ein
zwei drei wochen nicht auf meinem kanal
corbin kamen sondern ich mich eher so
auf die pos es hat doch alles ein
bisschen eckig gehen dann wenn ihr das
mit der maus so vergleicht er sich nicht
so schnell ich hab mich total in die bio
verliebt also dieses spiel wo man sich
aufrüsten kann und mit sachen abschießen
und so avancierte rio ist sie ja was was
das auch cool ist das liegt halt echt
kacke komm ich drücke ich jetzt die
maustaste und jetzt setzt das erst ein
und jetzt ruckelt das hier wie kacke nur
wegen diesem blöden hektoliter auf tod
freut mich sonnenscheins ich habe jetzt
mal laura graphics angemacht und es ist
es läuft nicht besser aber ich es ist es
ist jetzt alles schwarz irgendwie das
mit dem rausschmiss hat echt cool so
dass man genau sehen kann wo man
irgendwie lang an und die map baut sich
quasi nach und nach auch weil sich
danach die hingehen und ihr seht schon
dass martin nach und gibt mir gib mir
gebt mir food food ort du blöder toll
ich habe mich jetzt einfach mal ich
hätte genannt vielleicht wenn ich jetzt
von der community
die als das was ich bin akzeptiert oder
ich werde direkt von allen geschlachtet
und auseinandergenommen dann aufgegessen
einzelteilen tatsächlich sehr sehr
langweilig mit dieser erweiterung ich
kann mal einen großen
ok ok cool cool cool ich echt scheiße so
dazu wie war das noch ein bisschen
hickhack tja genau weil das jetzt halt
so ein bisschen hart von diesem hack ist
es halt guckt euch mal mein rechtes auge
an alter das ist eine kappe mit den
pollen deswegen kann ich nicht genau
leute anfangen mit der funktion dass
sich kurzzeitig schneller will und so
weiter und so fort
und ach guck mal hier sieht im
hintergrund übrigens claudia toll ich
bin wieder droht kissen das kommt
freitag in den shop freitag um 17 uhr in
der disco lee sagt das so oft weil wenn
ihr ein kissen bestellt ihr dann einen
unterschiedene sticker von mir bekommen
du nicht bekomme wirklich 99 der mails
die ich auch in meinem business schnell
bekomme ist nur auf meinen sohn ist ein
großer fan gewährt möglich dass ein
autogramm bekommen hey du meine katze
cook jeden tag deine videos kann die
flechten sticker von mir kriegen
siebzehnter sechste ab 17 uhr wenn ihr
ein kissen kauft kriegt den
unterschieden in sticker dazu so weit
kann ich raus zu im alter das ist
tatsächlich eine menge also ich finds
irland
mir und den nach vorne kann ich mir ich
darf euch den gelben hole ich mir da
alter wäre das kraske wird wenn ich ihn
getötet hätte ja toll lukrativste
einander töten sie sich selber darin
anderer da war es hier haben auch die
möglichkeit das ganze ausmaß deswegen
machen jetzt einmal disable extension
klick wieder auflegen und jetzt ist es
tatsächlich immer noch drin jetzt sind
wir wieder beim normalen ceo also wenn
ich jetzt auf druck ich bin ich auch
quasi direkt schnell und kann nicht mehr
raus und rein zoomen aber es hakt nicht
mehr
ich meine dass mit dem xoom ist schon
echt lang so man kann sehen wir uns also
jetzt nicht dass ich irgendwie nach
rechts fahren auf einmal so ein riesiges
ding und ja genauso wie das da unten
jetzt gerade um ein wort ja war ihr aaa
der usa klappt ich versuche noch mal
jetzt gegen einen recht erfolgreichen
runden zu kriegen ich sag euch leute und
ich glaube ihr seht auch gerade wenn ihr
das video gerade anschaut als ich mal
wenn ich gerade rede hört totti das
video aber ich bin nicht so gut in dem
game ist mir jetzt nur noch als ziel
diese große orange schlange da
vielleicht irgendwie zu töten dass er
schon sehr geil wenn ich überhaupt mal
das ende von der finden würde mein gott
ok fressen einfach auf und können wir
hier noch ein bisschen war
ich dachte ich könnte töten java toll
amerika danke echt super cool mit dir
zusammen zu spielen
ihre freunde das war's jetzt fertigen
die durch wollte euch nur mal diese
erweiterung solle der platz verspricht
das ganze video beim max gesehen dachte
dass er vielleicht ganz cool es hat
tatsächlich sehr hat geruckelt dass das
war dann halt nicht so cool manager
wieder trotzdem gefallen hat dann zeigt
sie mit einer bewertung und schreibt
über diesen kommentare was zunächst als
gaming kontrollieren wollte pacult